hi everyone that's really my great honor
to present this work um so uh what is
the biggest Trend in the next 20
years so um arguably to me I think this
is a you know we will become agan
society and the life expectancy will
keep increasing if you see it be become
it used to be very flat until the
Industrial Revolution and then almost
linearly rise in the last 100
years so with this expectation I think
within 20 years half of the population
will need assistance are we
ready so I always ask myself like 50
years later you know uh I should I need
expect my grandson to take care of me my
wife their parents their parents-in-law
their grandparents-in-law
or should I start work right now to
really make robots or using some make
some robots to take care of myself 50
years
later so if that is what I want to be
very respective person not use this old
senior people uh 50 years later so uh I
need to know there are certain needs I I
will I will need at that time so first I
need to basically I smart city I need to
go from A to B U also I need to some
robot I take care of myself um you know
at home and also I need some very
affordable um Health Care um uh like
providers such that if I got disease I
won't be go
bankrupt so once these uh services are
massively deployed I think the cost of
service will goes
down however how we can go through this
transition from now you only have one
unit to like 10 million units so I think
we really need trusty in this transition
and that arguably is the major obstacle
right now for the intelligent
robots TR words intelligent autonomy is
not um easy task the main reason is
first it has very high dimensional of
design space and also has a very vast of
design diverse tasks we have very
different sensors and also we have
different morphology of robots every
almost every kind of robot is totally
different and also we have very
different environment to use them and
the way to define the
tasks so those model can be super big it
could be like a several gigabyte of
parameters or even more so but however
to collect the data in the real world is
really costly and sometimes can even be
risky so this dismatch between the
demand in the input space and design
space and our capability to safely
collect the data is really the major
challenge for trustworthy intelligent
autonomy
so we need to be used to design to we we
need to be used to work in the in in an
area that data in sufficiency is almost
a default
setting so specifically uh the challenge
come from two fold one is the data will
be collected in sequence so you will you
always how have the the safety in the
long tail as a rare events and also Al
the needs or tasks or scenarios also
will unveil in sequence so we will
discover new needs and new uh situations
gradually so we need to be able to
generalize in this
case so this talk is about how to really
solve these two problems and um so first
challenge how we can solve the safety
with extreme values extreme values
because we always have extreme values
because of for most Mass produ ma Mass
massive production um if we naturally
collect the data the RIS the critical
data will always be sparse in a very
large
domain so we need to be able to
extrapolate from the head to the
tail so the head is model is defined as
the majority part in the distribution of
a certain parameter while the tail has a
more rough and spar
data so for example in driving the head
means you have a comfortable driving
environment that people are usually not
that aggressive but sometimes you will
encounter some um people will have road
range that will very broadly cut in so
the challenge the task is how we can
predict the behavior of the tail use the
data in the
head so this extreme value and this data
imbalance can be very extreme for
example with some simple statistics
people estimate that you need 11 billion
miles to prove a a is safer than a human
driver in a naturalistic
driving so 11 billion miles is a very
large number that equals you drive from
here to the Sun and come back 100
times so we cannot really conduct such a
you know experiment
for every new version of your
software right so how to really we need
to do some smarter
things and one way to do that is through
data reeing so you you know you need
more data in the tail because the cost
of the risk lie in the
tail so we can shift our sampling and
make it different from the naturalistic
distribution
so we can sample inside this blue curve
we can sample at this red curve at the
tail cross the boundary cross the know
add the boundary of the it to be safe or
unsafe so this can be done and then
after you collect the data you can
remember how dist skill the statistics
from PX to p p x and you can calculate U
the expectation in the original space
with importantance some
right remember how you how you shift the
distribution and the time use that as a
weight to get to give the weights for
the for the collected data in the new
distribution so this is important
sampling um in the classical important
sampl domain people have a concept U of
dominant point that can be used uh to
guarantee the efficient convergency so
for example the dominant point for this
2D H 1D space is this uh boundary
between safe and un safe for example in
2D space the dominant point will also at
the edge of the of the uh of the
boundary between this safe side and safe
set so you can instead of sample here as
a naturalistic uh setting you should
sample on the
boundary in this case we can prove we
have uh exponential convergency of the
risk where we
encounter however for real world real
world application with a high
dimensional
input it's actually not that
easy for example if you have two kinds
of different uh failure mode and you
only sample one mode and shift the
distribution from the normal
distribution to the nominal position to
one only one to the mode and you only
sample this and ignore the other part is
a huge
risk one potential uh case is that you
ignore the the other mode so you
underestimate your
risk the other one if you're super in a
rare RAR case that you happen to sample
the other case but because you already
sampled it here then this kind of
phenomenon will result in instability of
of calculation so you will have very
large variance in this case and make it
canver even slower than a ninal
sampol so that's because the high
dimensional space of the intell autonomy
and inti dimensional space is very
common in the in the in uh in in the uh
intelligent autonomy that's actually how
we Define the intelligent autonomy that
is able to deal with high dial space for
example um the high dimensional may come
from vision for this is a like a sign
you have images and input space could be
millions of pixels it could also result
from the temporal space so even you have
you you design auton vehicle you have SE
several cars in nearby um area and you
drive for a certain um time in certain
time interval so you have
Dynamics at different time so it's it's
it's the high dimensional with vision
times the high dimensional at time in
time so high dimension is very
common so U how to do that so one of the
approach that I'm wor working on in the
past years is that we say to beat a
beast you need another
Beast right so um to deal with high
dimensional space that's created by Deep
learning we also use the Deep learning
to help the important sampling so this
is we call the Deep important sampling
the idea is very straightforward that is
if you want to estimate the dominant
point of this um risky areas you use
deep you use deep learning to estimate
the boundary so that after you estimate
the boundary let's assume that deep
learning use activation as a r l which
is a linear pie wise function then you
can move the distribution to each of
this uh Edge in the uh pwi linear
function so that uh the whole problem
converted to a mixed integer Pro
programming and mixed integer
programming has very standard Solutions
and packages so you can discover those
important uh
areas this is a good problem uh this is
a good method however uh doing so that
is you need to consider every edge of
the deep
learning right but you may have like
millions of neurons and you need to
consider millions of Gan distribution
that can be very very computational
inefficient so next step to solve the
computational problem so we already
solved the sampling problem with the
Deep important sampling but how to solve
the computation problem we propose the
computational efficient and Rob
evaluation of safety package in this
case so we are using the uh this is
original Deep learning that have many
edges it's the same number of neural we
use um the number the number of edress
equals the number of neural we use use
we can simplify that by
linearize part of the deep neuron
Network so that we are trumped
those unnecessary neural network and we
have some um the outer approximation
with the neuron networ so we can still
perform similar have a similar
performance the Improvement is great is
is is a significant so if you only use
naturalistic way for example in this
kind of simulation of this a three car
simulation you may need to run a amounts
uh you know the compation need to run a
mount so it's it's not it's very heavy
even for
simulation and expensive for simulation
well you with deep important sampling so
we reduce the sampling to very small
number but we have very relatively
larger computational time in this um uh
light sha shading
area furthermore we Trump the the uh we
we chop the the neural network to a
degree and created this certified
approach that we reduce we almost have
the same sampling um data efficiency but
here we also have the computational
efficiency so that only take two hours
so this two hours performance is
equivalent to a month simulation so
think about if you launch a company
right so you spend next days lot of
company they just run gpus that's maybe
the most costly Dev asset you have if
you can save
40 time sorry 20 * 20 cost by this two
steps so how much money money you can
cut in this case and also time so I
think this is the important um so I ramp
up this Research into a certain flow
flow so first you collect data in the
real world then you build a simulator
for the real world using naturalistic
statistics you skill the statistics and
create a Accel cated the environment and
then you can U from this environment you
have two things one is you can estimate
the risk another one you can identify
the important failure examples then you
can use important sampling skill to
convert the results from this acceler
environment to the naturalis environment
and understand the risk of large
deployment in the original
space so to achieve this four steps you
need three
skills one is
you need to have a good generative AI
that can simulate the world second you
need a different you have a two box of
important samplings such that you can
deal with the high dimensional in V
input space and also in time space and
finally you need to some way to really
Implement uh the the sampling uh in
physical world or augmented
reality so after that you can you you'll
be able to access the safety the level
of risk then you can make decisions so
to make decisions with the uh the safety
so we argument the traditional uh markon
decision process that try to optimize
the reward with another cost so you are
not only maximize the reward function
but also you have a constraint if you're
smaller than kaapa then M your safety
level is acceptable so that will be the
constraint optimization
problem so this kind of constraint
optimization problem is naturally a
multitask problem so you have potential
two risks by imposing this constraint
one is your training can be unstable
because you have con you have oposition
right so this two will intervene with
here you have training
instability you also have some issue for
deployment well this optimization may
now be robust to the
uncertainty so why because think about
this so this is the the two areas that I
showed in this um uh consider
optimization you want to optimize along
xaxis for your reward you also want to
keep the uh the risk and a certain
threshold so the feasible set for all
policy here each point is one policy uh
you the the phys policy will be be be be
below this threshold so the Shaded area
is out the fible
policy and if you want to do
optimization you want to increase the x
value and also make this y- AIS value
smaller than the threshold then
naturally the optimality the optimal
policy will be
here so what's the problem with
that the problem is that you are on the
boundary of
safety no matter how design it you will
always on the boundary of safety so uh
you always have a temptation to go to
this area because you want to increase
your reward so whenever you do increase
your reward you cross this boundary so
if you already even you can search for
optimal solution then if there's any
disturbance in the system you will cross
the boundary and become you know
unsafe so that's what we call Temptation
so this phenomenon is very easy to
understand but very nicely studied in
the reinforced learning
domain and you may argue okay what if
there is no TR between the safety and
the performance in this case you'll have
this kind of negative gradient between
the safety and the re uh and the reward
in this case we call the trivial safe
Pro reinforcement problem because you
can just ignore the safety your
naturally will result in the safe zone
so that's that's but however in the
reality almost all the problem I
encounter has this tra of between the
performance and your
safety so how to deal with that um so
you can see here um the safe the safe R
is not robust there is a simple example
I I showed so for example this car just
want to move along the periphery of the
circle but need to avoid this uh this
yellow uh
area so the optimal solution will be you
just
follow um you just follow this going
straight at this area and then follow
the circle U otherwise so if you give
this the P the the perception system a
little bit disturbance and noise then
the training will be very unstable and
the deployment can be very wrong so
that's what happens on the
right so because this intervene between
reward and the and safety constraint the
traditional robust safe reinforcement
learning robust reinforcement will not
not work so robust reinforcement means
so I will give you the worst and
hopefully you can handle the the normal
right so in this case for example one uh
SOA algorithm U called mad that's they
want to this perturb your action as much
as possible will not work in this case
because in this case um you are nudging
it's like you are driving but there
another person always nudging
you you you can very hard to learn what
is safety because you always get this a
distraction right so we want to then
what to do so we want to say you can
either like precisely Whenever there is
a safety uh issue you you Notch that
person but keep it quiet when it's
normal driving so then that person learn
okay I canot I can I can drive um I
cannot drive too fast but interesting
this is normal uh this is a first
approach maximize the the the water will
maximize the safety cost so that you're
resilient to the
invisibility um the the second approach
which is I think very interesting of
this twood dimensional optimization is
that instead of perturbing this in the y
direction you can also perur in the X
Direction you're it's like you're
encouraging the the driver to do to
drive faster say you're super good drive
fast you can do you can do more and then
eventually this driver will have this
right so safety isue so this is another
way you can also perturb in the X
Direction and the interesting we found
if you can actually make this two of
Theo you can use this two of those
together and have a very versatile and
robust probation to the system and let
the the uh the system learn how to keep
a distance from this
threshold again remember each point here
represent a policy that has millions of
neuron parameters so keep a distance
from a certain line is not that
trivial okay so so then after that we
say oh we can also improve the
efficiency of the system we make the
system even harder so here we are using
the system called Safety gym so the this
agent need to want to go to the uh each
dot well avoid this uh blue static up
Circle and this moving purple up Circles
so we compare our approach with other uh
approaches so you can see all the all
policy approaches that use historical
data will fail to cfy the safety
constraint it should be behind below
this straight line but all the UN policy
approach are capable to um keep it safe
however if you look at this figure under
the right that xais is how many mistakes
you make y AIS is how fast you'll learn
so you can our method can be zero
magnitude of efficiency than them
because xaxis is actually in the log
scale so using a constraint vinal policy
optimization so we can actually make um
our robot learn much faster with the
same number of mistakes so this is a
really important as well so not only
this small robot we also try different
kinds of robots for examp spider and
Jones Joon is actually very very
challenging because if you have a
certain safety problem joone will fall
to the ground and you basically cannot
learn too much from it so it's very
sparse reward and cost trade
off so not only safety this meth
actually when I call safety I actually
means any critical metrix that you need
a threshold to make it acceptable for
other people in the society for example
could be a bias and fairness it could be
some energy consumption for
sustainability also could be privacy
leakage so they all have similar is once
we have a large scale deployment those
harmfulness will actually show up very
um very
significantly so that's the first
challenge the Second Challenge is that
not only you need to extrapolate to the
tail you also need to deal with new
tasks
the new task um is a u is the the
problem come from that you can sometimes
this a multi model you have a different
mode and it's very challenging to model
them with a single neuron Network you'll
overfit so you the better have a
conditional distribution that
conditional what task you are you will
build the
distribution so this is important uh for
example U you need need to learn how
many task you have um for example this
kind of a task so if you design a car
that driving this kind of simulation uh
this environment it can be really
difficult to use a single neuron Network
model everything happening
here right you can see this really very
intelligent it's driven by it's it's not
it's not movie is a uh indeed happened
inopia that you have many cars many
lanes uh driving together with
pedestrian buses and trucks
so how to deal with this
situation so the challenge is that you
do not know how many vehicles are will
surrounding you at you know at each time
and you do not know how many scenarios
there are so I say okay I say I told my
student okay if you want to study from
General ability start from here so if
you can solve that problem you probably
can solve all the problem in driving so
we this we we didn't go to S we download
the video from YouTube and we do some uh
image processing to have the location of
each
car and then uh we model because a it's
a the number of cars change all the time
so we use a gan process to model the
field so how other vehicle will interact
with you and we use the hierarchical dur
process to uh sample how many scenarios
you are so basically that's UNS surprise
learning and interestingly we find that
there are eight different kind of
scenarios if you can handle them well
then you're almost 80% time you're
you're fine so it's a little bit
complicated than our now now driving
situation but obviously people over
there already recognize this
patterns that's why actually they can
drive right so they can
generalize so then we say okay so after
you can model the situation you can make
decision so we make we put this model
into this uh reinforced learning uh
domain and we make this a model um model
based reinforced learning the only
difference that this model can sample
different tasks at each time so if we
observe some scenario that is familiar
to what I have seen I will take the old
model I bring out of the old model if I
have seen something really unique I
model that a new one and start to learn
a new model so that's the uh Mo task
diagnostic model based reinforc
learning well since now we have tasks
defined in this um Enterprise Learning P
when you bring the task also bring some
issues uh they can you have you can have
redundant tasks you may miss some tasks
you may also have wrong label task this
all because the imbalanced the data size
between the
tasks right so for example we then we
start to solve those problem we
encounter for example in this case um
you when you do the manipulation uh the
different locations of the object should
not be considered u a different tasks
it's just similar to to say that for
different you know this is the same
scenario if you rotate it a little bit
you should still consider the same task
purely statis method cannot capture this
you basically need a um a a way to
really incorporate the Symmetry uh into
the analysis so what we did is we
incorporate a equivalent neural
convolution n network and converted
everything and train and convert
everything into this symmetric space and
then we can do the sampling and Analysis
and learning this symmetric space so
that in this case if we change the
location of the task if we change that
to the 3D dimension of the task it can
be still considered the same task so
even though certain tasks have a lot of
data we will not divide them into
different task to have
redundancy another one another example
is that uh you may miss some tasks
because that task is particular hard to
collect for example uh in self-driving
case you it's very easy very Rel cheap
to collect the data for normal
driving you may collect a lot of them
it's also rather easy to to recognize
data that have Collision because the
police will come right so you know
basically you you record what happened
and do the Reconstruction of the sin it
is very challenging to collect data for
near
misses that something you know you
frighten another people got frightened
but there's no cion but that's exactly
the self driving C should have pay
attention to at this stage so collect
those kind of this is very um it's very
challenging so what we did is we collect
we have the data set of the normal
driving we have the data set of the
collision and we use the varal auto uh
this a conditional version Auto encoder
to incorporate this two such that we can
um by tuning the game be the weight
between this two data set we can
generally stale uh the the sin that is
similar more similar to safe or more
similar to unsafe cion scenario so we
have a linear interpolation of the
latent space so that if you tune this
Lambda to one you'll be fully safe it to
zero to be fully uh Collision in this
case we can interpretate them uh and
generate some near misses so near me it
should be another task in this case so
that's another uh
example so what if uh the models are
sometimes the model are super big for
example know nowadays where Transformer
models are very popular so you know we
say oh in this case the data may not
almost always not not insufficient
so instead of the index to indicate each
task you say maybe we can use more
information from this um from you know
data we collect for each tasks so the
first uh you know because those
Transformer models you can see they're
super big for example Robocat that just
published by Deep Mind has 1.2 billion
parameters to train right how many
experiments can you conduct right so so
that can be ex extremely challenging so
how to build a um more informative index
so what people did in natural L natural
natural language processing is that us
they using so- called pump based
learning in this case you give some
guidance to the to the to the machine so
that you can generalize much more uh
with a better
Direction so then what will be the
proper format for prompt for
autonomy so we are using in this case we
are using demos as a prompt to train the
uh the robot it's like you have a robot
at home you bought a robot right and
then you say okay I will show you how to
clean the floor but only twice okay
after that you need to figure out
yourself you can use this two
demonstration by you as a prompt and
give it to the robot and robot will it
will be much more sufficient uh
efficient and helpful to the robot in
this case given the prompt so we just
given the experiment as uh the the
demonstration as a prompt and input that
into the Transformer structure we found
that will be super efficient uh in
learning uh tasks and handling different
kind of
tasks so you can also have a hyper
parameter a hypernet to incorporate the
same prompt and directly change certain
part of of the Transformer to make it
more expressive expressive for example
the you can only change 05% of parameter
in the Transformer and the light the
light robot to be able to handle some
taxs it have never seen
before so this are also shown to be
super expens uh effective than the
traditional approach by only uh handle
at the at the input SP input
domain um but more realistically so we
are now using multiple task at the
beginning that the robots usually
trained with a certain task in the
factory uh in the factory mode um and
then when the robot deploy to the real
world environment you you always have
some new things you want the robot to do
right and int robot should be able to
handle those new tasks so this is a
continual learning problem that is you
always have something new to do and you
need to be able to not forget what you
were taught in the
past so this is a challenging because if
you train a full model find full model
that'll be either hard to adapt to the
real the the new task because the in the
the in to use a a small new
demonstration and also it has because
you fine tune the whole model you will
have a um like a cast casty forgetting
issue so one way is that you have a
several copy of them just like what we
did in this um chaotic driving situ
intersection situation but that will be
very data
inefficient another way is that you only
change a part of the the Hat the the the
the model but it's not very expressive
so a a simple solution is that instead
of um you know changing that or make a
copy you make a few copies of the small
part of this uh Transformer and once you
and label them with tasks for different
task you change a part of the
Transformer so we call this tail task
specific adapter for imitation learning
because this is a similar to the tail of
the real world uh animal um that they
are all lightweighted compared to the
body they will not negatively affect the
body's functionality and they can also
be used differently for different
purposes so what exactly we do uh we did
is U is uh you know we have three ways
to impose uh three places to impose such
a small change one is you can use a in
par in sequential way you can put that
into the Transformer another one you can
use in parallel to the weights of the
Transformer and the third one just as we
discussed can use as a
prompt so these are the three ways and
we found actually they can be very
effective uh we tried with 130 different
tasks and u u in the home house home
house of robot and we divide into the
kitchen spal go object living room and
study room case I me test uh there this
figure shows that our model can learn
things much faster as this red curve
shows but also do not forget after after
this task is done well other model you
can see even you you also they also
learn they quickly forget the
tasks so um compare also compared to
these three tasks and we found that the
the lower the par the parallel approach
is more effective than the sequential
one and also the prompt
one so uh essentially we only change
0.1% of the parameter but we save the a
big portion of the memory and the and
and and computational efficiency and
achieve the backward Transformer uh
transfer capability which deal with the
cast forgetting and also the forward
generalization
capability so uh and also this task can
be wrong too so um we U sometimes you
know we we divide into this task into
five categories but sometimes we can be
the category can be wrong for example if
you put this you have a studio right so
it's a kitchen it's a living room or is
a study room right if you live in in
studio so that can be hard because uh
one way again use the uh robust learning
you can have the worst case the position
assume you have the worst wrong uh
identification of the task to its policy
uh that can be very conservative
basically the robot that they're allow
to do anything another one is you can
have distribution now uh robustness but
the robot is still a little bit
conservative because you basically treat
every the correlation between all all
the tasks to be independent but in
reality some task are more relevant
correlated to other
tasks they may some sometimes may seem U
more often together in particular
situation so in this case we have this
hierarchical structure of the tasks so
for example for a new uh robot uh task
that we can have a samples of we can
have likelihood of the which uh of this
tasks belong to which uh this
environment belong to this which tasks
and for three different say uh they call
task swits they have a different um
likelihood for certain tasks to happen
in this case sometime because we know
some tasks are more similar to the
others then we can incorporate this pray
knowledge into the hierarchal
structure this hierarchal structure is
actually very common in in an other
application for example you sometimes
you know in City a and City B uh you may
know there have different driving Styles
right like a bigger bigger city or
smaller City very different drive in for
example a number would not get my PhD
and the Chicago so uh in Chicago you
don't expect people to really yeld to
you right so you need to really learn
how to make your change the L uh well a
number basically people Stu and let you
go because there's almost no traffic so
in this case if you have this you know
this already C A you have a better guess
of what the other people will do so you
will better guess what kind of task you
will encoun
right so this is the again this is very
common not only in driving but in
robotics you have this level of
extraction of taxonomy of tasks and also
in robots and the very fun thing we did
is with this football that if you for
example how many players will against it
you may have a higher different
likelihood you know to play the the
football tactics sometimes if you want
over like a five another players you may
just shoot directly or just pass the
weight and pass the ball so have a
hierarchical of uh this uh this research
hierarchy of task is very important and
that actually enable us to develop the
gr group distributional robust algorithm
that will theoretically prove that is
more uh effective and less
conservative so I want to say that
generation is is very common it's not
only inopia but actually in other
countries too so you mean uh you really
need to learn the knowledge and transfer
the knowledge in this
case so uh there could be another
situation that you absolutely have no
knowledge at all you don't have any data
this is a real no I encountered this one
at Pittsburgh uh I saw was some they're
shooting a movie but actually that's
that's a real
accident um how to deal with this kind
of things right so uh that without any
data point you need to really leverage
on our knowledge from
somewhere right so for example what we
did uh we can leverage the knowledge
from laws and standards that's already
written right you can model for example
we work with the U chin University in
China and then digitalize all the
traffic laws in China and then uh during
the uh Beijing Winter Olympic you know
they make the they change the local law
for particular Lane in this case you can
easily uh change your logic with the
linear temporal logic and then adapt it
to the new Lane a new law without uh
even need to retre the model so that's
if you have some rule you can embed the
rule if you have some common senses uh
you can use trees to very easily embed
that one and this trees can be a also
can be generated by a gener model right
so for example uh we have uh we want to
generate the scenarios for laa right so
they have millions of design space u how
to really we always lack of data so how
to really generate the realistic
scenario Aros so we incorporate three
knowledge rule that you know car will
not in the sky right so car will always
in the same almost in the same direction
in one one lane and that make our
generative space much more uh
constrained and realistic with the
sufficient data insufficient data and
then we use this one to uh to rank the
popular uh lighta Point Cloud algorith
up DET algorithm and shows very
effective using this we call S attack
rather than only per a certain point
with this Lia scenario and also
sometimes knowledge can be represented
by a cal graph uh for example you see
this a you have a big bus here block The
Pedestrian and there is a car coming in
so you need to understand that in this
thing uh these three cars are most
important and the reason you have
accident because this a big car parked
there and those other cars are not very
important so you need to really
understand these three things are
important there other two notes are
irrelevant rather than just use
correlations correlations be can be very
misleading for example you know there is
you know in the rush hour you usually
drive slow but that doesn't means at no
three like 400 p.m you always need to
drive
slow so that's because you're in C area
drive slow that's because the traffic
jam drive slow not because it's a 4 4
430 you drive slow so this can be very
misleading in many cases and very
dangerous for purely data Jour
approach so you can embed this knowledge
into the uh into the reinforcement
structure and then learn the knowledge
and the the the model together so that
can be much more effective and this can
be used to also solve the S to real
problem for example if you play a table
hockey in real world you can always play
very well but in reality it's not
because same real
problem and you can impose the this uh
this uh correlation between all kind of
parameters and and be uh and and and
study which parameter has the the most
important influence of your of your
performance right and then uh after you
learn those things your design space
your optimization space become much much
much more uh sparse so that you can do
very effective optimization with uh
small size of
data so uh then you can with that you
can uh do something really cool for
example play hoys this is a really cheap
table so you can you can it's very
difficult because the uncertainty in the
reality and also play some uh like
tricks uh you know people have like a
try like a thousand times too you know
on YouTube and Tik Tok you know they
they make some tricks uh with this
approach you can do that with a robot
very
easily okay so uh but sometimes when
absolutely no data is
available um then U that's U that's
unknown unknown problem right so
creation by the way is actually a
unknown unknown problem and animals are
somehow really good at it so for example
those animals can use the tools in a way
you may not
expect so how we can do that so one U
interesting idea is that we can leverage
information on the internet as a PR
knowledge for creation where large
enough model so in this case we say oh
we want to bring the the milk into this
area but we put a hammer there and we
can incorp we can really leverage on the
larger model so that the the robot learn
how to bring the um the the milk with
this uh with this tools and also you
also need to learn how to sequentially
uh use the tools and sometimes how to
manufacture those tools uh tools to do
something
new and here you can see U if you may
also need to learn how to U go from sofa
to the the black cushion by using the
surfing board or pushing a blocks to go
to the the sofa and even lift the cube
uh by making a
lever so those are very creative ways to
use tools and no traditional approach
can can be able to do it but we say oh
how about let's ask a GPT and what
happen right and then we designed such a
uh approach uh by using the analyzer
calculator planner and coder so the to
the co not only the planning and idea is
generated by gbt but also the code is
generated by it and it it seems that it
work uh in this situation so in this
case if you have absolutely no knowledge
you can ask all the information you can
search all the information
online okay so in summary we have this
three approaches and three problems when
we deploy intelligent robot at large
scale and also now we are moving to the
physical world I think it's very
important to consider that the physical
world the difference between physical
world and the simulation uh for example
you can see U you know those all the s
vehicles they have very different roof
right so they have different configur of
sensors and we realize that in one of
the paper if you change those sensor
angle a little bit the performance will
drop by 10% well in the like SOA Ben
Baseline uh like uh Baseline uh data
like leaderboard their difference only
like 0.1% so it's very important to say
that physical world is very powerful to
solve some problem but also could be
very influential not only in perception
but in the morphology
design so uh by using those tools and we
summarize all the methodologies we can
design we can do the design and
evaluation and towards the trust wory
autonomy and I'm now working on the you
know some of my research become the uh
standard and protocols I'm working also
working with a lot of Industry people to
make it
happen so uh also for some academic
tools I collect data in Pittsburgh and
make a large scale simulators based on
uh some open source
software so and also some uh safe uh RL
uh safe RL offline tools for faster uh
uh learning for good database and also
for offline learning so in summary uh
today we talk about U the generous
ability safety evaluation explainability
with causality certain robustness and
embodiment and eventually we hope we can
have a human CC
uh approach to design the trustor CI so
this knowledge was summarized in my
course um at Samu um so we are also
broadcast the the same course to uh to
Rwanda right
now so uh finally I think I hope we can
deploy the intelligent autonomy at a
large scale uh you know as a this a made
by confusious I say okay so after you
got intelligence you really need to be
crustworthy uh that was basically 2,000
years 2000 years ago
okay with that thank you for your
listening and um welcome questions thank
[Applause]
you curious about you mentioned large
language models as a semantic overlay
what's your experience is that is that a
promising path some people are I think
two things I think are important you're
useful for BL model one is uh I think is
really important to learn uh to get
information from normal people and they
are not structured right so you need to
uh traditional is questionnaire but with
the lock model we can very easily to get
uh feedback from Human for example like
a dver he say oh I don't like the system
it should be D more aggressively right
so or dve too slow so you have some
description in natural language so to
have the feedback and preference for
human is important second you know for
certain area that you have zero data uh
you it's better it's also good idea to
use l search about potential Solutions
so I always I always think that for
problem we are known we have known
Solutions we should directly use the
solution for a problem we do not know
even how to start we can use other
approach to
explore and here and I also know
sometimes people like to chat more
outside questions in of the whole group
um but thanks so much let's hear it
again for our
[Applause]
speaker